i was very happy to observe um um
uh russell brandt recently
interviewed um um
shapiro what's this oh ben shapiro yeah
yeah yeah
ben shapiro and there was a lot of
disagreement but but there was a mutual
come from completely different positions
russell wright is on the left obviously
stranger beerus on the right and then
they reversed it later ben shapiro
had him on his show and it was very
really very pleasant to watch they were
both able to
express clearly their viewpoints and
their mental positions
without attacking each other at all so
there was an
undercurrent of awareness as i would
call it
which is a which is it it's a dimension
of consciousness that is extremely
important
for humans to uh to realize within
themselves because if you
if you're not aware of what your mind is
doing
so there's some separation from the
mental position which is the thought
and who you are who you are
is the aware presence in the background
that frees you from being possessed
by thoughts
so what's the best way to immunize
yourself against that i mean i think
about that all the time
i try uh to bring information to people
in as honest
and decent way as possible and sometimes
i think i'm pretty decent probably
sometimes not so decent
but i have no doubt that i have that
veil as well and i have
probable blind spots due to my history
or
whatever it might be how do you how do
you actually climb out of something
if you're if you're unaware of it at
some level yes to become aware of one's
thinking
there's no easy answer to that to many
people it happens naturally
for example it it tends to happen
sometimes to people
on a personal level whose thinking
becomes
so negative about the the in other words
the stories they tell themselves
let's talk about narratives that people
have in them
in their heads in their minds my life is
so dreadful
and all all i've been treated so
unfairly by society and life and i've
had
everything bad always happens to me i
know these things because
when i was young i i had similar
thoughts in my
mind very negative negative narratives
and the more negative narratives you
have for some people it's
the negative narratives about the world
out there which is
everything is evil and they're out too
they're how to sabotage me and and so on
all the negative narrative may be about
myself there's something wrong with me
whatever it may be it leads to an
enormous amount of suffering emotional
suffering
because the emotion is usually a
reflection of
what you're telling yourself in your
mind
creates a reflex reflection on the
emotional level
so if your narrative is very negative
you feel you then experience very
negative emotions
anger sadness resentment
or in if if you're very if you
if your narrative is very much directly
towards the future
the fearful future then there's a lot of
anxiety and fear because the future is
so uncertain
and so people who go into a lot of
suffering at some point
they sometimes realize
that the suffering they experience is
actually produced by their own minds
for example somebody might suddenly wake
up and say
for the for the past few hours i've
been engaged in negative thinking about
myself and the world
wow isn't that amazing and i have these
thoughts that could
that come back again they recur again
and again
thoughts about myself things i tell
myself about myself
and so these thoughts are creating so
much suffering
you can stand back and say well i'm so
negative
why am i always criticizing people why
am i always complaining about everything
this this is the beginning of becoming
aware of what's happening
complaining is a big pattern in many
people's minds
they love complaining complaining about
what's out there complaining about my
life
and running out them complaining
and i'm not talking about complaining
when
you have the ability to change a
situation then sometimes it's
good to speak out when there's
possibility of change
but many cases people just complain
because
it makes the ego feel bigger because the
more i complain about
others the more the bigger my ego feels
because i'm right and they are all
wrong and you have to be right
you're you're you're perfectly spelling
out uh exactly why i get off social
media because we all suffer
we all suffer from that if i get a lot
of retweets it has a certain
dopamine effect to me or or sometimes i
open it up and i'll look for negative
comments even though i don't consider
myself
a negative person yes no but the very
important thing when you have
interviews or dialogues with people uh
there's usually uh there's a background
field of um
a peaceful coming together there's a
background field
of there's a certain connection even if
what your opinion and the person you're
interviewing maybe
a very different viewpoints very
different thoughts
nevertheless you are not so identified
with the viewpoint
the mental position that
any body who questions your viewpoint is
unconsciously regarded as an enemy that
needs to be defeated
so that you have an awareness perhaps
you don't call it awareness
when you when you haven't when you
conduct interviews
there's still an under a background
field of
peace there is not antagonism
i observed the same i was very happy to
observe
um uh
russell brands recently interviewed
um um shapiro what's his
uh ben shapiro yeah yeah
ben shapiro and there was a lot of
disagreement but but there was a mutual
completely different positions russell
wright is on the left
obviously beerus on the right and then
they reversed it later ben shapiro had
him on his show
and it was very really very pleasant to
watch they were both able to
express clearly their viewpoints and
their mental positions
without attacking each other at all so
there was an
undercurrent of awareness as i would
call it
which is a which is it is a dimension of
consciousness that is extremely
important
for humans to uh to realize within
themselves because if you
if you're not aware of what your mind is
doing
so there's some separation from
the mental position which is the thought
and who you
are who you are is the aware
presence in the background that frees
you
from being possessed by thoughts
by narratives based by mental positions
and so it takes the ego out of the
interaction
and then you can have a fruitful
interaction so you don't need to give up
your viewpoints or your mental positions
but not be totally identified with it so
that anybody who questions it becomes
your enemy
it's so interesting because obviously
you're not a political beast
but what you're saying here is so
applicable to everything that everyone's
fighting about
sort of politically these days but i
want to ask you one one other thing
about the state of the world before we
move into a little bit of the technology
part of this and the off the grid sense
which is that i think you know a bit
about my story i used to consider myself
an atheist for probably most of my adult
life
and i don't anymore for probably about
four or five years i would say
i would say i'm more of a believer now
than i've ever been in my adult life
and i think that is connected to my
ability to sort of stay
sane within a very polarized political
time and as someone that puts their
opinions out there
and i i wonder what you think about that
just sort of where what the state of
belief is
at the moment you know when we factor in
this last year and a half
and lockdowns and fearfulness of a
disease and
you know if i walk outside this might
happen and and so on
uh yes it's uh the
belief uh really should lead to
a little bit of an uh
deeper realization belief alone uh
is fine is to be to believe that that
your life has a purpose
is good that there is a greater purpose
to life than just your personal life and
somehow your personal life leads to
needs to be in alignment with a greater
purpose that pervades the universe
there is an an intelligence
that is transcendent to a
sense perceived reality that is beyond
that
a an intelligence that
manifests itself in this world
but is also beyond this world if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about spirituality instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
spirituality playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell